what is up guys welcome to my barrows
guide slash tips for mid to upper levels
first thing I want to mention is that
this guy does not concrete there are
many ways to do barrows this is just the
way I think is the most efficient in
this video I am assuming that you know
the basic things about barrows such as
the patterns on the doors that unlock
them can easily look these up I'm also
assuming that you know that using magic
is always the best option for Carol and
using range for Arum is also the best
option this guide is not an in-depth
guide on how barrows works or how to do
it if you are new this is a guide for
people that have done barrels before but
are looking to make barrows better and
easier or maybe don't know how to do
barrows all that efficiently if you want
a guide on everything about barrows
leave a comment and I will make sure to
make a video in the near future about
everything you need to know about
barrows alright let's get started
starting with the gear setups I prefer
and think are the best before I show you
the gear I think it is imperative that I
show you guys my combat level and my
stats Sohan screen is the combat level
in my stats my combat level is 91 my
stats are 72 attack 73 strength 72
defense 87 range 52 prayer 76 mage and
81 hit points all right now let's get
started into the gear the first setup I
am going to show you is the one that I
recommend you use and it does require 70
defense don't worry there will be
another setup option with this setup I'm
using my best melee gear that is tanky
and also has para bonuses I am using the
varrock helm
toric play body for rock plate skirt
dragon boots regen bracelets ears ring
trident of the Seas Book of Darkness
peaceful blessing fire cape and the
occult necklace you want to use the
occult necklace because it gives a 10%
boost on mage damage which is very
helpful against barrows the reason we
are not using major armor to boost our
major attack is because the Barrows
brothers have no mage defense so
therefore magic armor does not increase
how easy it is to kill them in our
inventory we have the Gothic steai body
gothics chops toxic blowpipe fury
archers ring ava's accumulator and a
ranging potion all of which we will use
to kill mmm and these skeletons we also
have a spade to get to the brothers
three prayer potions which we will only
use a few if any sips of a stamina
potion barrows teleports to get to
barrows a ring of dueling to teleport to
clan lures after our trip and the rest
of the inventory is filled with monk
fish the second setup I only recommend
if you do not have the money for the
other armor or if you do not have 70
defense this setup is basically the same
except we are now using the helm of
NATO's not the gothic dragon hide body
and the gut thanks dragon hi chaps if
you cannot afford the region bracelet
use barrows gloves or the combat
bracelet I am only you
the regen bracelet because I do not have
barrows gloves yeah if you cannot afford
the seer slash Archer ring only wield
the ring of dueling and use the extra
space in the inventory for food
additionally use the best cape you have
and the only other offhand I would
recommend would be the DFS if you do not
have dragon boots simply wear the best
boots you have I cannot stress anymore
how any other set up is not worth it for
this love do not use the graceful set
method as that is a complete waste of
time you will use more pair pots more
food and you will take way more damage
all you need to do is bring one stamina
potion and you will never run out of
energy you barely even have to use the
stamina potion also I'd like to
reiterate do not wear magic armor as it
does not help you at all alright let's
get started into my tips my first tip
may seem like an obvious one but my
first tip is to have your bank set up so
it's super easy to regear in case you do
have to rehear after a trip have your
prayer pots your ranging potion your
stamina potion and your food all in an
area where you can get to right away so
in this instance it is in my first tab
so when I click the bank everything is
right here and I can easily read ear now
I will talk about the two possible
routes you should be taking at barrows
the first route is this the reasoning
behind this route is it is the cost
efficient route you will use the least
amount of prayer pods it does sometimes
vary on the order of barrows but
typically this will save you the most
money because it utilizes the fact that
you are attacking the brothers that
require prayer as the first brothers you
attack now the second route which is
also the one I use this route is the
fastest possible route and therefore is
my recommended route however if money is
a problem feel free to use the other
route as you will save one two three
food and maybe a few sips of Prayer my
next tip is to have your quick prayer
set up for protect from melee it may
seem obvious but it is very helpful once
you have that go ahead and dig to attack
Derrick once you open the coffin click
the quick prayers then run towards the
stairs so you can get away as quickly as
possible and not waste any time as a
bonus you can also prayer flick all the
brothers to save prayer points and pots
once you have got your last hit on Derek
go ahead and click the stairs and
quickly get away once you've got two
Arum in the center go ahead and switch
to your range gear and drink your
ranging potion then dig and do not
immediately pray from arum unless you
have no HP but go ahead and use the
toxic blowpipe special to rehe l' your
health in this instance I did not have
to use prayer but sometimes you will
have to use prayer just be ready to put
on your protect from mage if you need it
once you have done all T brothers and
have found the hit and tunnel go ahead
and enter it and immediately zoom your
zoom out as far as you can go into the
corner right here and then look for
which one is the open door as you can
see all three if you angle it properly
as you can see I saw the doors right
there so now I'm gonna search for the
closest door and it happens to be this
one I switched to my range gear to get
ready to kill my three skeletons but
then the Barrows brother appeared you
are always gonna want to kill three
skeletons on your way to the chest and
if the Barrows brother pops up before
you get to the chest go ahead and kill
the Barrows brother but after you kill
the Barrows brother go ahead and kill
three skeletons do not kill any more
than three as that is the max potential
you can get three skeletons gives you
88% reward potential and that is the
highest that you need and be most
efficient anymore is not worth it any
less is not worth it and finally once
you have got your loot from the chest go
ahead and rub your ring of dueling and
go to clan wars if you need to regear
there is a bank right there so if you
want to regear go ahead and go to the
bank and rege ear other than that run to
the portal and enter it entering this
portal resets your stats your prayer and
your energy and your health sort of go
ahead and teleport to barrows and now
you have full stats now I will share
some tips
then I will recap and show you guys what
a full run looks like and how long it
takes the treading of the sea slash
whomp is the best option for barrows
then the Ivan's staff and then any other
staff slash spell that you want to use
the blowpipe is the best for Arum then
the magic short bow imbued then the rune
crossbow additionally you can also burst
the brothers and safespot them and use
zero prayer potions also if you have
higher melee stats feel free to use the
wave for skeletons in the KC
alright let's go ahead and recap have
your bank set up for an easy reader to
save time
use your max Tinky and pair efficient
armor and do not use magic armor decide
which route you want to take and I
prefer personally the quickest route
stand by these stairs when attacking the
brothers so you can make an easy escape
prayer flick if you want to save some
money always use range for Arum and use
your blowpipe special to heal once you
enter the barrows tunnel zoom out and
look in the middle chamber to see which
door is going to open at the end on your
way to the last door
make sure to attack only three skeletons
as that is the most efficient amount of
KC and finally once you get your loot go
ahead and teleport to clan Mors to
regear and regain your stats now I will
show you guys what a run looks like for
me and how long it typically takes
[Music]
[Applause]
alright guys that is the end of the
video it took me about five and a half
minutes for that run and typically my
runs are around five minutes I imagine
if you have better stats in gear you
will be able to do it in three minutes
efficiently I hope you guys liked this
guide slash tip video if you did go
ahead and give it a thumbs up so I know
you guys liked it if you guys have any
comments or suggestions for a new video
make sure to let me know in the comments
section again I want to thank you guys
so much for the support on YouTube
through comments and ingame messages it
means a lot I'm really trying to get to
1k subs so make sure to smash that
subscribe button also I have a clan chat
it is just my name heart blitz and it's
currently a PV m / PvP slash hangout
clan
there's also now a discord for it and
the link is in the description again
thanks for watching the whole video and
good luck at barrows thanks for watching
guys stay tuned for my next video
[Music]